après avoir enterré la hache de guerre
avec chains.com et Magnus Carlsen on se
demande se retrouve au cœur d'une
nouvelle affaire insolite cette fois-ci
l'opposant à Vladimir cramique dans un
tournoi en ligne il le bat avec les
pièces noires dans une partie très
naturelle aucun doute là-dessus pourtant
vexer est toujours un peu soupçonneux
l'ancien champion du monde refuse le
combat dans la revanche et laisse à son
adversaire la possibilité de lui placer
le mat de l'imbécile plutôt que gagner
de la sorte d'IMA ne préfère abandonner
et dans la foulée il a posté une vidéo
sur Twitter où il aimait le souhait de
s'entraîner avec cramique discuter échec
autour d'un vrai échiquier pour prouver
sa bonne foi cramer car agit
positivement invitée en Imane alors
rejoindre sur un tournoi mais ce dernier
a du point sans refusé puisqu'il est en
route pour Mexico au championnat du
monde junior où il va être tête de série
numéro 1 et tenter de remporter la
couronne